des patrouilles qui déambulent dans les
rues de la grosse pomme ces volontaires
cherche à protéger les personnes
d'origine asiatique à new york
il dénonce une hausse des agressions et
du harcèlement à l'encontre de cette
communauté ces derniers temps les
membres de ce groupe de bénévoles
veulent d'agir en complément de la
police new yorkaise
on est les yeux les oreilles de la
police de new york
en gros on surveille ce qui se passe
dans la rue on est ce qu'ils ne parlent
pas la langue on peut aider à faire une
traduction et s'il se passe quoi que ce
soit on les aide à appeler la police
notre but est de nous assurer de garder
la communauté en sécurité
on veut affirmer notre présence avec
nous les jeunes fléau pour que les gens
nous voient de loi et que ceux qui
veulent commettre un délit réfléchisse à
deux fois
une présence qui a tendance à rassurer
les personnes concernées comme
l'expliquent cette restauratrice
quand je les vois je me sens davantage
en sécurité grâce à eux je n'ai pas peur
de venir faire mes courses ici pour
soutenir les commerces de la communauté
le groupe bénévole appelle à la
bienveillance et veut faire entendre un
message de paix et d'égalité qui notre
couleur de peau notre langue sont très
différentes mais je pense qu'on est tous
égaux et on se sent menacé par ceux qui
pensent autrement ceux qui pensent
qu'ils valent mieux que nous et que nous
n'avons rien à faire dans ce pays
mais en réalité on est tous venus dans
ce pays pour les mêmes raisons il y a
une dizaine de jours l'amérique a été
frappé par la tuerie d'atlanta des
fusillades dans des salons de massage
qui ont fait huit victimes pour la
plupart d'origine asiatique